hu salut c'est monsieur aujourd'hui dans
notre série de l'été en plein cagnard
on est tous nés quoi allant des 18-19
juillet enfin cagnard sacrament le
soleil magnifique le soleil cook le ciel
bleu c'est incroyable aujourd'hui je
vous parlais de sony je vais vous parler
du sony xperia x3 qu'il va arriver très
prochainement pascal commerçants va
balancer toutes les caractéristiques
techniques du sony xperia x3 il ya le
ixe l2 qui sentirait pas longtemps pour
faire un petit parallèle on va regarder
ce que devrait être ce sony xperia x2 3
et on va le comparer aux widgets de haut
niveau
regardez-moi ciel bleu regardez-moi
soleil est ce qu'on n'est pas bien on
crame aujourd'hui je vais donc vous
parler du sony xperia x7 3 parce que
sony a sorti en début d'année son higgs
est de 2 pouces est vraiment un modèle
qui a souffert notoriété et franchement
j'ai trouvé super bien il était un petit
peu effacée par les galaxy s ne fais
plus de samsung et le pépin pro a
carrément fini le boulot comme ça
personne n'en a parlé et c'est vraiment
dommage parce que c'était vraiment un
smartphone qui était super avec un écran
hyper intéressant au niveau photo vidéo
il fait vraiment des choses qui sont
super et c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment dommage qu'on n'ait pas à
séparer et donc là j'espère qu'avec ce
sony ericsson 3 qui va être présenté à
l'ifa normalement renvoyer un peu plus
de bois j'espère qu'il aura une
meilleure couverture médiatique et qui
souffrira pas cette fois-ci de la sortie
d'une note 9 qu'on va pouvoir prendre en
main exactement au même moment
normalement le z3 doit avoir exactement
le même écran que le ixe aide de
c'est-à-dire un écran de 5,5 pouces avec
une résolution de 2160 parmi les 80
pixels il faut savoir que c'est un écran
hd avec de meilleures couleurs de
meilleurs contrastes un écran de
meilleure qualité
donc ça point positif au niveau du sort
que ça doit être un certain dragon 845
de qualcomm de toute façon ça pourrait
globalement pas être autre chose parce
que pour l'instant pâle comme n'a pas
sorti de soc plus puissants contrat
serait le best of the best
au lieu de 4 gigas de ram pour le ixe et
de hydra voir si giga de ram le même
stockage 64 giga extensible il faut
savoir que il faisait 2 est extensible
jusqu'à 420 ya à voir ce que fera ce x3
est ce qu'il montera jusqu'à 2 tera
comme le font certains zones de la
concurrence why not sure le higgs est de
vous avez une batterie de trois mille
180 millions terreur et là on pourra
voir une batterie de 3240 millions paire
eur et là où sony bat des records c'est
au niveau de la caméra pour la photo et
la vidéo c'est vraiment leur point fort
et il faut savoir que les objectifs sony
équipe beaucoup de smartphones du marché
donc la pente court quand ce sont pour
leurs produits sont plutôt bien sortis
vous auriez donc à l'arrière un double
module photo avec un capteur de 10 9
mégapixels et un capteur de 12
mégapixels
la bouderie revendre votre portrait avec
un bel éphèbe hockey up il faut savoir
que son xv de la rose et des capteurs
ont 19 mégapixels
vous avez une ouverture de f 2.0
c'est pas forcément le plus lumineux du
marché faut savoir pour faire des photos
jusqu'à 1,10 au des 12
1800 et la vidéo vous avez un iso de cap
il à l'avant sur l'exode de vous avez
une caméra de 5 mégapixels la voudriez
avoir une caméra de 3 mégapixels il faut
savoir que la saq mégapixels avec
objectif qui ouvrait à f 2.2 qui fait
une mise à jour là du panasonic du
siamois non panasonic moi j'ai acheté 5
j'ai l'impression que ça va mieux vous
me dites vous dites mon commentaire si
vous trouvez qu'il ya moins de flou par
rapport aux autres vidéos effectivement
il y avait des flous là j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un meilleur suivi
cool bon on en revienne aux tic 7,3 il
devrait tourner sous android en reo
j'imagine qu'il aura pas des
caractéristiques inférieur où il faisait
2 donc voudriez avoir un minima une
certification ip68 un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 un autofocus hybride
intuitif une stabilisation sur cinq axes
et je trouve que c'est vraiment de ce
côté là que ce qu'ils aident de a
vraiment pas trop attirer l'attention
des médias du grand public des
influences en règle générale et ça c'est
vraiment dommage parce que vous avez
quand même une excellente qualité en
termes de photos et vidéos sur le x2
pourrait faire du slow motion 960 images
par seconde en full hd en 1080p 1920 par
1080 alors sur le samsung galaxy s 9
pouvait faire uniquement en 720p en hd
de ce point de vue là il est supérieur
au samsung galaxy s 9
effectivement le s9 une lentille
ouverture variable va être meilleur en
conditions de faible luminosité
le pen impro également mais je trouve
que vraiment ce higgs est 2e et
probablement sur l'exacte 3 non pas du
tout à rougir par rapport à la
concurrence
vous pouvez faire de la vidéo en 4k hdr
high dynamic et lounge vous invite
d'ailleurs à liestal type d'échangé
vidéo sur le x2 pour revoir un petit peu
tout ça un design qui avait été revu et
corrigé par rapport au xv et danse avec
sony souffrait de design un petit peu
old school un petit peu désuet par
rapport à la concurrence alors sans
forcément parler d'encoches paddick sony
à vous mettre une coche au-dessus puis
de toute façon je suis pas sûr que ça
ait un sens par rapport à l'adn de sony
mais c'est vrai que d'une manière
générale leur design était un petit peu
anciens c'est vraiment le point négatif
avec la gamme z 2 ils ont été un peu
plus loin ils sont un petit peu remis en
question à voir son travail que ceux y 3
est ce qu'ils vont continuer de
progresser
est ce que vous nous proposez un vrai
borderless ça ça reste à voir
eric 7 3 qui proposait sur site de
mobile fun au tarif de 8 149 99 euros
ttc
on n'est pas sur ce soit le vrai prix il
sera peut-être moins cher pour l'instant
il n'y a toujours pas eu d'annoncé
officielle de la part de sony
effectivement ce les commerçants
connaîtrait elle
fiche technique mais le prix rien n'est
moins sûr donc ça on en parle un peu
plus tard je vous invite à rester
connectés et à vous abonner comme le x2
le xgd3 devrait avoir de la recharge
sans fil
profitez d'un florilège dr comme le
dynamique vibes sound system jiaxin
système de vibration dynamique
lorsque vous regardez un film une vidéo
epic a souhaité que ça envoie un peu
votre smartphone vibre j'ai pas été
hyper hyper convaincu parce que je
trouvais que bon ça rajoute et pas
énormément mais je peux comprendre que
des personnes qui aiment pour regarder
un film d'action le téléphone vibre
il ya un côté un peu plus immersif ça
peut être cool ils ont également
présenté sa version douanes ew said une
modélisation en trois dimensions de
votre visage si vous avez une imprimante
3d vous pouvez imprimer votre tronche
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça peut être
sympa en tout cas ce qu'on voit est ce
qui est super intéressant c'est que sony
se renouvelle propose plus de modèles
essaye de rester toujours au goût du
jour assez génial d'ailleurs sony si
vous me regardez je suis partante un
contact est comme ça on va se faire
plaisir on va les tester
je sais que derrière il ya plein de
monde intéressé par les modèles de sony
il ya assez peu de tests on n'en parle
pas énormément c'est dommage pour moi je
suis intéressée peut contacter dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous seriez intéressés par ces
smartphones de sony est ce que vous
aviez le xz-1 x à 2x à un exode de
est-ce que ce il z3 pourrait vous
intéresser
vous ne marquez tout ça en commentaire
pour dire ce que vous en pensez et puis
surtout si vous trouvez que sony va dans
le bon sens du point de vue de ses
smartphones
et si vous appréciez leur qualité ce
soit au niveau de la photo de la vidéo
au niveau de tout ça vous marque tout ça
bien évidemment on est connecté vous
invite comme la dame laissez dégeler
pouces et moi je retourne à la bondrée
parce que c'est pas tout mais on est en
été s'il ya bien un moment où il faut
profiter c'est maintenant voilà donc je
vous dis à très bientôt soyez sages
je vous embrasse
et